writer Tim Ferriss talked about how
eventually the mainstream media could
not ignore anymore maybe at the for our
work needed for our body off that so he
had broken free of sort of this
obscurity but many of the people that we
know have not been a very talented
beautiful work but they're battling
against people who have crossed over
that threshold so how do you compete
with the spider-man's the Avengers when
you're still in that spear level and you
have
it's character-driven but no names
stolen shots
honey battle instead of security and
we're free or
a numbers game time right well how do
you do it you have to be loud you have
to be really really loud you have to do
something that's unexpected that the
other people won't do you have to do
something to get noticed the 4-hour
workweek we for our work week I can't
talk is a brilliant title that's a title
that begins to get loud and get some
attention by the way I think one of the
worst things about most indie movies is
their titles suck their titles do not
declare what they are and make you want
to go see them
and if we could have really good indie
movie titles I think we would start to
begin to break through that a little bit
so you've got to do something
loud outrageous unexpected which means
conceptual it doesn't mean expensive
loud is not expensive loud is just loud
loud is just something that gets noticed
so you have to something gets noticed
and I don't know what that is it really
depends on every single project and
every project has its own unique thing
that it needs to do to get noticed and
sometimes it has nothing at all to do
with the project itself it's just
something that sits beside the project
horror movies often do this with really
loud and outrageous and graphically
violent one-sheets which is kind of a
lower chakra example but it's an example
that you instantly recognise and that's
and there is a certain core audience
that if its gory enough they will go to
it so if you can loudly say this is the
goriest movie out this month the
gorefest people will come and and see
that right so I don't think that's only
relevant for horror movies I think
that's also
relevant for movies for romantic
comedies for movies for senior citizens
like for movies for various specific
communities now the other thing is you
have to think about what is breaking
through and having success me I don't
think it means being on 5500 screens I
think that could success could be being
on a hundred screens and for a really
great independent movie being on a
hundred of 500 screens I think is
massive breakthrough breakout success
and you totally get noticed so part of
it is lowering the ceiling a little bit
on what your expectations are just the
realities of today's marketplace and in
my experience of talking to exhibitors
they are really hungry to have good
independent movies you know all the big
exhibition chains now actually have
marketing departments that are solely
directed to helping independent movies
find their audiences
AMC Pacific Krekorian Regal they all
have SWAT teams that are just for
marketing movies now this is not
marketing from the distributors this is
marketing on the theatre icks exhibitor
side trying to get butts in those seats
because exhibitors have a huge problem
the problem is that most of the time
there are not people in their seats
exhibitors experienced an annual basis
85% of their seats going empty I see you
raising your eyes like it's a shocking
number right you say like in theaters
only 50% of the seats are full on an
annual basis yeah that's right
eighty-five percent of the seats to fill
so if you as an independent filmmaker
come up with a really innovative way to
say hey I can help you fill your seats
on Monday and Tuesday nights or
Wednesday afternoons which is when it's
empty right how many times have you gone
to a matinee on Wednesday at one o'clock
and you're the only person in the
theatre if you could help fill those
seats exhibitors would come running to
you because they really want to sell
their popcorn and they really love
Louise
you